[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bons sauts nicolas
et pimprenelle ont l'air très sage ce
soir ils ne font pas de bruit
pourvu qu'il ne me prépare pas une
blague non nounours ils travaillent ils
travaillent ou je te revoir ça autre bon
les jeunes pousses mourmelon
ne fait pas nous on est à l'école tu
vois bien et on apprend à faire des tas
de choses très amusante voyons bord pour
ce truc j'en sors assieds toi nous et ne
bouge pas on va te choper la chanson de
l'école au bout le gecko dieu à l'école
pas besoin d'être grand
juste quatre ou cinq ans il suffit tout
simplement qu'elle se conduire châtiment
balle l'école on s'assied sur 9 ans et
tous sont d'accord et pimentent appel
laissant comme tout le monde est content
on m'a dit qu'en cas les cantons de
s'amuser
la jolie les gones à la grande maison et
des crayons ou le fait que ben pâton où
l'on chante des chansons à la gentille
et khaled deux filles et deux garçons
on y apprend des leçons aux joueurs mais
ted ballon
a sion au jeu fut signalé je ne peux
accompagner parce que c'est à l'école
cancale et des salles et des goûts et
des petits et grands savent aussi qu on
l'aimera tout c'est vous qui veulent
l'école usait mozilla les prime est
calculé ils iraient pour dessiner tenait
beaucoup
[Musique]
bravo les enfants elle est très belle
votre chanson mais vous n'y allez pas
encore à l'école mais papa il a dit que
moi j'irais même est roger et moi aussi
j'aimerais bien mais si vous vous
coucher tôt chaque soir car il se lève
de bon matin les écoles tunisiennes 1 3
mais où sont ils en écho chez bravo les
enfants vous ferez de très bons échos
liés et on travaillera beaucoup j'en
suis sûr la jettent allen au bas d'un an
[Musique]
bonne nuit et nous c'est pas demain
tenus nicolas pimprenelle corps bien
[Musique]
bonne nuit tous les petits enfants
faites vite votre toilette embrasse bien
fort vos parents et aller vite au dodo
pour aller à l'école
ils feront se coucher de paul bord à
demain d'un ennemi fait de pauvres
[Musique]